in retrospect some would say
october 23rd 1985 was the day the
chinese communist party
died
by the mid 80s virtually every inch of
the country had been transformed by well
over a decade of radical economic reform
but after that day in october when deng
xiaoping explicitly described state
policy as quote letting some people get
rich first the proverbial cat was
undeniably and seemingly irreversibly
out of the bag
it didn't matter what ism defined its
economy or in the words of dung what
color the cat was
only that it was effective at catching
mice
for ideology had no place in this new
china
class struggle and collectivization had
already given way to new inequalities
but with dung's unequivocal
proclamations gone too was even the
facade
there was nothing especially subtle
about it
any american visitor to china in the
roughly 30 years after 1980 myself
included inevitably returns with the
same surprised observation
china looks more capitalist than america
and that's saying something
most iconically there are the mcdonald's
so so many mcdonald's
and you can't miss the kfc's
twice as many in fact as in america
street vendors everywhere trying to make
a buck
shopping malls apple stores and designer
handbags
chinese consumerism is globally
unmatched in its ostentatiousness
but the culture of capitalism has seeped
much deeper than mere brand names
the american obsession with buying
houses launched the greatest financial
crisis of the 21st century
yet is thoroughly put to shame by the
chinese who collect third and even
fourth homes all empty bought before
completion and likely to never be lived
in by anyone like the rest of the world
collects stamps
then there are the class distinctions
americans are no strangers to economic
inequality but at least in theory no law
stops you from packing up and moving to
beverly hills
in china your place of birth quite
literally determines your place in the
world
household registration or huko means you
can move from middle of nowhere gansu
province to cosmopolitan shanghai but
its public schools hospitals and jobs
will forever be legally off limits
place of birth matters everywhere but
only in china do authorities not even
pretend otherwise
and if that doesn't convince you
socialism with chinese characteristics
is but a euphemism for state capitalism
there's plenty more evidence to choose
from
starting in 1980 international
corporations could buy advertising space
in the communist party's official
magazine
albeit with one exception coca-cola was
explicitly banned
in the two years between 1986 and 88
student support for communism fell from
38 percent to just 6.1
and bear in mind these are officially
sanctioned surveys
deng xiaoping even warned that although
china should maintain vigilance against
the right it should be primarily wary of
the left
since the death of mao the communist
party has maintained only the thinnest
veneer of tradition in the interest of
continuity acting out the motions of
increasingly vague five-year plans an
increasingly predictable politburo
procedure
but while the rest of the world has
largely played along with this political
theater we've all long since realized
underneath this nearly transparent
maoist packaging is pure raw big mac
loving unadulterated capitalism in all
but name
[Music]
then xi jinping happened
today after a decade of this new era you
wouldn't just have to be an optimist to
not see how things have changed
you'd truly have to be living under a
rock
and to notice the similarities between
mao and xi is to be confronted with an
uncomfortable question
did this maoist revival emerge
spontaneously
implausibly manufactured by one man
alone
or did even the most clear-eyed china
watchers fundamentally misunderstand the
past five decades
one way or another a reappraisal is
overdue
sponsored by curiosity stream and nebula
get both for just 15 bucks a year and
watched my latest nebula exclusive
original debunking the myth that china
lifted 800 million people out of poverty
despite being one of the most common
myths about china i've been unable to
cover it for fear of demonetization
until now
thanks to nebula
sign up and get access to all five of
these exclusive original episodes and
much more
on the 9th of september 1976
china experienced the most traumatic and
destabilizing thing that can happen to a
cult of personality
the death of that personality
with the sole exception perhaps of north
korea's kim il-sung no country has ever
had so many of its political eggs in one
basket
china was the communist party and the
communist party was mao
his complete monopoly on power created a
volatile vacuum of power and all but
guaranteed a secession crisis after his
fatal heart attack
how you interpret what happens next is
where history diverges
in one version the one most of us have
come to believe the death of mao forced
the party indeed the entire country to
do some serious soul searching
his absence gave dung's generation room
to critically re-examine the horrors of
the past quarter century and steer the
country in a new direction
there's simply no denying that the scale
and speed of china's modernization was a
direct result of these reforms
had mao's four confidants not been
purged a mere month after his death the
word tiktok would probably still mean an
early 2000s pop song
you wouldn't know what shenzhen is today
in a very different version of history
deng xiaoping's greatest innovation is
not liberalizing the chinese economy
exactly but knowing the secret passwords
to join the globalized american-led
export market
in this world china's post mao leaders
realize there's a practical limit to the
amount of starvation the average person
is willing to endure in the name of
peasant revolution
they realize after 89 that photographs
of tanks do a lot of damage to the
national brand and firing squads are bad
for business
at home china maintains the prominence
of mao and continues speaking the
language of socialism
but abroad it emphasizes the with
chinese characteristics part
it's a ruse the rest of the world is
either too naive to notice or too
blinded by dollar signs to act on
the truth it would seem is an uneasy mix
of both
though probably more of the latter
on one hand mao's death did allow for
the entry of a new previously mythical m
word to the government's vocabulary
mistake
accompanying it were democracy
opposition and even if you can believe
it human rights though its precise
definition may have been shall we say
lost in translation
yet no sooner had dung uttered these
words when old red lines were redrawn
in other words the scope of permissible
speech widened by a remarkable degree in
a remarkably short period of time
but dung's four cardinal principles
still left a lot to be
desired in the party's own words mao's
contributions to the chinese revolution
far outweigh his mistakes
another important thing to note
something that may have been dismissed
as a mere historical detail for the 50
years between then and now but today in
2022 is clearly anything but is the fact
that mao's death led to the very first
policy debates in the prc
for the first time in the country's
history you could say things like hmm
maybe mao was only 70 correct
that's a pretty big deal
much bigger than it sounds
that 30 tolerance could be the
difference between say china being
comfortable importing foreign-made mrna
vaccines and sealing its borders shut
for years to come
anyway history remembers the victor and
dung's reformist camp was decisively
victorious
but that makes it all too easy to forget
that there were other factions
the more maoist leftist coalition slowly
faded from the spotlight
but in hindsight never quite disappeared
leftists couldn't exactly speak their
minds freely yet still enjoyed some
protection under the banner of the
unassailable great chairman
censorship is always a cat and mouse
game and the more aggressive the cats
the more clever become the mice
political groups in china quickly
learned that they could get away with
just a little bit more while waving a
little red book
ultimately leftists were at the mercy of
the reformist-led communist party who
reluctantly tolerated their existence if
only as a counterbalance to the right
but what dung couldn't have predicted
was that several earth-shattering global
crises many years later would
unexpectedly tip the balance once again
in the leftists favor
allowing them to re-emerge from the
shadows
however profoundly the fall of the
soviet union may have affected the world
it hit especially close to home in china
the two countries had long since
splintered ideologically but they still
had more in common than not
with the russians out of the picture and
no other large industrialized role
models to be found china was effectively
left to carry the mantle of socialism
alone
this was uncharted territory and the
stakes clearly were existential
but what exactly was the lesson for
chinese leaders
while dung's reformers learned that the
soviets had liberalized too slowly
leftists took away the opposite
conclusion that reform was the problem
whatever disagreements lingered they
were thoroughly put to rest after 2008
just as the soviet collapse triggered
anxious introspection and delivered a
political win for the leftist coalition
so too did the global financial crisis
reverberate in china
while americans were preoccupied with
real estate and the rest of the world
with its second third and fourth order
effects
china buckled down for a storm
pumping an unfathomable amount of credit
into its economy in anticipation of hard
times to come
shiny airports
roads to the middle of nowhere
roads connecting to middle of nowheres
and yes the colossal high-speed rail
network the rest of the world marvels at
but the looming storm never arrived
even though many of these roads proved
useless and high-speed trains to the
desert sat predictably empty when the
expected alternative was mass
unemployment it felt a lot like a
victory
not only did china emerge from the
global financial crisis unscathed but it
did so as the only major economy to
actually grow
and by double digits no less
in just a few short months chinese
leaders both lost their reverence for
u.s economic policy
arguably u.s policy period
and gained immense self-confidence in
their own system
or rather
regained
the last time china stood this tall was
under mao
the 2008 beijing olympics didn't hurt
either
meanwhile around that same time the son
of a powerful revolutionary named
boshilai rises to national fame
precisely by tapping into this maoist
nostalgia
beau was not a normal chinese bureaucrat
he was charismatic
he liked the spotlight
and most importantly he was not boring
this highly unusual personal approach to
politics both made him extremely
well-liked and probably led to his
ultimate demise
in short boshilai was described as mini
mao and his policies as ushering in
chinese socialism 3.0
he built affordable housing saved
struggling state enterprises and helped
level the playing field for poor
migrants
above all he proved that socialism at
least one particular flavor still had
cachet in china
not unlike bernie sanders or donald
trump his popularity exposed a long
dormant political segment
now nothing changed overnight
new mcdonald's were still being built
the iphone was only beginning to achieve
velocity largely built with chinese
manufacturing and bought by the chinese
middle class
but if you were looking closely the
stage had been set
the chinese leftist movement was making
a comeback
when xi jinping inherited power in 2012
he was reportedly shocked to discover
cia spies working at the highest levels
of the party
that of course was concerning on its own
but even more concerning was what that
meant
after three decades of market reform
china had become near fatally capitalist
we're not talking about dc lobbyist
crony capitalism here
there was a second-hand market for cadre
positions
let that sink in
you could buy your way into the
communist party
albeit under the table
that was how the cia allegedly
infiltrated the party
they simply paid
and if cadres were willing to sell out
their country that easily it goes
without saying
the only chairman these corrupt
officials were loyal to was the mao
staring back at them on banknotes
she was horrified to find china occupied
by capitalists
as we saw in this earlier video
public-private collusion enabled
breakneck economic growth
it turns out the right kind of
corruption can actually speed up
developments
but we see now that it also threatens
such necessities to the survival of the
communist party as its chain of command
she realized this and launched a
multi-year anti-corruption campaign that
took down not hundreds or thousands but
millions of bureaucrats across china
in fact it never really ended
many on the outside interpreted this
campaign through the lens of a dictator
accumulating power
corruption after all is a common pretext
for eliminating one's rivals
but this misses the forest for the trees
of course xi jinping took out some
competitors along the way
but it's doubtful he identified a
million and a half competitors
and of course he's trying to consolidate
power
but to what end
a closer look at history reveals that
many of xi's signature campaigns began
under his predecessor hujin tao
although the ship was turning too slowly
for many to notice the new course had
long been set
as any socialist will tell you
capitalism becomes entrenched the
vanguard of the proletariat cadres tend
to lose sight of their comrades once
they own a bmw
the difference between who and she is
not so much ideology but that only the
latter has the political power to
overcome this obstacle
xi jinping didn't instigate the
socialist revival but he was the first
to make it practically possible
and he doesn't have much time
the usual explanation for the communist
party's continued existence amidst a sea
of capitalism is performance legitimacy
or the implicit
agreement we will make you rich it goes
and you won't challenge our authority
but perhaps this theory says more about
us than it does about china
if you're really looking there's a
mountain of evidence suggesting sincere
ideology was there all along
it's obvious in retrospect that reform
had a lifespan
economic growth can't go on indefinitely
even in a country of 1.4 billion you can
only build so many high-speed trains
this places the party on tenuous ground
because its legitimacy would be at the
whim of volatile stock markets and real
estate bubbles
but even if growth did continue the
communist party's unique claim to power
would weaken with each passing year
while china was getting rich lots of
other countries were getting rich too
reform era china didn't have a
compelling source of national pride
listen closely and china's own leaders
have made clear that making people rich
was never its complete strategy
this emphasis on economic growth was
always a temporary and partial measure
even reformers believed in some version
of socialism
they just disagreed on how best to get
there
although it's ruled by a communist party
it does not claim to be a communist
state
communism after all is a utopian
destination that even its most ardent
supporters don't believe is on the
horizon anytime soon
this is the fundamental source of
confusion
outsiders even or especially experts not
familiar with chinese history
see a country replete with markets and
privately owned companies
they see as we did that even communist
party ranks can be bought for cash
and conclude that socialism is obviously
a facade
a misunderstanding which ironically has
suited china quite well
but look even closer and it's clear that
this is itself a facade
deng xiaoping said this explicitly
the state could never truly distance
itself from mao because he was
inseparable from the party
the writing has been on the wall if only
we were looking since 1980 just three
years after mao's death
the party was only ever going to deviate
from its origins so much
and remember that was the best case
coming from mr reform and opening
himself
now there's some truth to the implicit
agreement
you can easily see how the proletariat
would be more or less patient on the
path to utopia depending on how many big
macs they can afford
but while reform could have been longer
shorter stricter or looser depending on
which coalition won
the existence of the communist party
requires that it eventually justify its
monopoly on power
otherwise anyone could rule china
the other common justification for the
party is the argument that despite its
flaws it did lift 800 million people out
of poverty
it's the retort that any critique of
china is met with
but there's just one problem
it's not really true
i've wanted to debunk this myth for
years but the only way to do so honestly
is with a rather grim and gruesome
inspection of chinese history which
demonetization makes impossible on
youtube
thanks to nebula i was finally able to
make this video which is now my fifth
full-length nebula exclusive original
video the amazing thing is that by
signing up for the curiosity stream and
nebula bundle you can watch all five of
these exclusive videos plus all these
normal videos sponsor free and other
great nebula originals for just 15 bucks
a year
in other words you can start getting
about 50 percent more poly matter for
just 15 bucks a year by signing up to
the curiosity stream and nebula bundle
on curiosity stream you'll find great
feature-length documentaries like this
closer look at one of history's most
notoriously evil men
click the link on screen right now to
get both nebula and curiosity stream for
15 bucks a year and go watch my original
series over on nebula